now to this story this morning the World
Health Organization says measles cases
rose 300% worldwide in the first three
months of 2019 think about that compared
with the same period last year and there
are new numbers from the CDC that show
555 cases have been reported in the u.s.
across 20 states this year's measles is
extremely contagious and can be deadly
dr. David agus joins us from Los Angeles
good morning Senora this is now the
second largest number of measles cases
since the infection was eliminated in
2000 why this spike now this is you know
this is obviously very worrisome this is
one of the most contagious diseases
known this is one of the few diseases
where you COFF and hours later the
particles can actually infect somebody
what's happening now is is that people
travel to other countries where there is
measles and they brought it back to the
United States and there are pockets in
the US where there's no vaccination so
there are pockets for religious reasons
personal exemptions beliefs where people
are not vaccinating the children and
then they come back from these countries
spread the measles and obviously 555
cases now we're going to eclipse any
other number and you know in 2000 we
declared it eliminated in the United
States of America so what are the
symptoms if you have measles symptoms
happen classically anywhere from one to
three weeks after exposure and it's rash
its fever up to 103 104 but what's
really worrisome is in the early 1960s
before vaccination 500 people died a
year 48,000 hospitalizations 4,000 cases
of inflammation of the brain are
encephalitis so it can be severe and
especially in young kids because we
don't classically vaccinate till a year
of age and people haven't been
vaccinated pregnant women are obviously
very worrisome when there's a spread of
this disease and yet dr. agus there are
still so many parents who are not
convinced what can you say what can you
do to convince them that this is very
crucial do you know to me it's the same
thing that happened with smoking is that
was very hard to get our country to stop
smoking but once the secondhand smoke
argument came out you're not affecting
you but you're affecting your children
that people near you around you
it made an impact the same is true here
you don't vaccinate your child you can
kill another child but sighs the
ramifications are your own child so it's
that second hand effect here we have to
push on we as a community have to
protect each other and we have to use it
through data and science the measles
vaccine works all right dr. agus thank
you I hope you touched somebody this
morning that will make a different
decision thank you so much